I'm going to show you the best remedy to
get rid of tartar as well as to prevent
tartar from coming back what is tartar
well tartar is this uh
calcified pale yellow hard growth on the
inside of your teeth that tends to get
into your gums it can create um
gingivitis it can create bad breath and
if we take a look at what tartar really
is it's actually a collection a colony
of
bacteria that is in a slime that then
has calcified and that's just the way
that microorganisms survive in nature
over 95% of all bacteria in nature uh
survive as biofilms now if you ever walk
through the woods and you saw a little
stream and you reach down and pick up
one of the rocks in the Stream on the
outer part of it you're going to feel
it's kind of slimy that's biofilms I
mean even in your pool if people don't
use enough chlorine or other things
natural things like certain salts and
and things then you'll get this slimy
thing at the bottom of your pool and
these biofilms are not just bacteria
there's a bit of fungus as well yeast
and candida and they are not on keto in
other words they like carbs they ferment
carbohydrates in your mouth and then
what happens is they release uh lactic
acid and so they make your mouth really
acid and then acid has the potential to
leech away your calcium and break down
your teeth giving you cavities and all
sorts of wear and tear in your teeth now
I'm going to show you one of the best
anti-t Tarter uh toothpaste that you can
make at home very inexpensively and it's
very effective and very natural you know
when they looked at ancient Egyptian
like mummy tombs the teeth were pretty
messed up they had a lot of dental
problems and it probably came from all
the beer and the bread that they
consumed which is the perfect food to
feed these bacteria in the mouth but
they used a type of toothpaste composed
of ox hoof ashes burnt eggshells and
volcanic ash that's a great mixture that
probably creat some abrasiveness right
and then the ancient Greeks used a
different type of toothpaste made out of
burnt shells and they use powdered talc
which is kind of like a combination
between magnesium and uh silicon and
then they mix a little salt and honey in
there and then the Romans used Crush
bones oyster shells and charcoal with a
little bark so the problem I see with
that formula it's a bit abrasive and it
can wear down your teeth so this formula
is very non-abrasive you have clove oil
peppermint oil or cinnamon oil or
turmeric powder so in a little container
you can just put like three drops of one
of these or like a little pinch of
turmeric if you want to use that now the
next thing you're going to put in this
little container okay is hydrogen
peroxide all you need is like a four of
a teaspoon which is about 1.25 ml now
the interesting thing about hydrogen
peroxide is that your body makes it to
actually kill bacteria and microbes so
you're not giving something the body
doesn't know what it is and hydrogen
peroxide is a very potent antimicrobial
that inhibits bof films the next thing
you're going to use is baking soda now I
know what you're thinking you're
thinking wow that's pretty gritty it's
going to be invasive but in actuality it
has a very low abrasivity which is
basically the ability to be abrasive
there's this uh metric or this scale
called the relative Dentin it's kind of
like a layer right underneath the
outside of the tooth so it's relative
Dentin abrasivity basically gives you
kind of a a rating system to know how
much something could you know break down
part of your teeth and baking soda is a
seven okay a seven compare that to
regular toothpaste which is between 70
and
250 so baking soda is actually not going
to grind down your teeth and baking soda
is sodium
bicarbonate so it adds alkalinity it
takes these acids and actually helps
neutralize them and our body makes
sodium bicarbonate it's a way that the
body can buffer some of these acids so
both hydrogen peroxide and sodium
bicarbonate are something that our body
makes so with baking soda you're going
to use A4 of a teaspoon then you're
going to add either raw honey or Manuka
honey but just add a four of a teaspoon
not very much but the key is it has to
be raw or else you're just basically
killing off the things that are
antibiofilm now raw honey also has
hydrogen peroxide in it now Manuka Honey
doesn't have the hydrogen peroxide but
it has some other things that regular
raw honey doesn't have a large amount of
to address this this problem then you're
going to add a half a cup of water which
is 118 mL of water and then you're going
to mix everything out real nice so then
you're going to brush your teeth with it
with a soft bristle toothbrush this way
we can preserve the teeth kill off this
film that is developing into Tartar and
you want to do that twice a day as a
side note vitamin K2 has some
interesting research that may also
inhibit the formation of tartar it's
it's kind of a mix review but I have
heard reports from quite a few people
that swear by it and they notice that
the inside of their their teeth are nice
and smooth when they take this K2 which
has a purpose of directing calcium into
the bone and out of the soft tissues now
since vitamin K2 is so new and so
important you should probably learn more
about it and I put a video up right here
check it
out